اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
خلافات البيت الابيض وكلاب حول اداره
الحرب في باخمه تظهر على السطح وواشنطن
تقول اوكرانيا لا تقبل نصائحها العسكريه
وزير خارجيه ايران يعلن التوصل لاتفاق
مبدئي مع واشنطن لتبادل سجناء
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تصف انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي بانه صادم ومقلق وتخفف من
وطاه ذلك على باقي البنوك
الى واشنطن لوضع اللمسات الاخيره على صفقه
غواصات نوويه الى استراليا والصين تترقب
مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا حيث نقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو عن
مسؤولين امريكيين تاكيدهم بان هناك خلافات
بين اداره بايدن واوكرانيا خلف الكواليس
حول اداره كييف للحرب الصحيفه ذكرت ان
الولايات المتحده نصحت اوكرانيا بالتخلي
عن باخموت لاستنزافها الموارد لكن
معتبره ان التخلي عن باقي يؤدي لخساره
دونيسك وباكملها مسؤولون امريكيون اشاروا
الى ان واشنطن ترى ان معركه باخموت ستحد
من قدره اوكرانيا على شن هجوم مضاد
المسؤولون اضافوا انه تم ابلاغ اوكرانيا
ان مهاجمتها للقرم ستعقد فرص الحل
اوكرانيا بالمقابل تجاهلت نصائح واشنطن
العسكريه ولم يظهر الرئيس
الاوكرانيا كافيا للدعم العسكري الامريكي
بحسب الصحيفه
اشارت ايضا نقلا عن مشرعينا امريكيين
قولهم ان هناك انقسام داخل اداره بايدن
حاليا حول المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
في الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]
هذا وبحسب القراءات ميدانيا قد تدخل معركه
بخموت في شرق البلاد مرحله جديده طبعا هذه
المرحله مرتبطه بقدره القوات الاوكرانيه
عشان هجوم مضاد على الروس في الوقت الذي
تعاني فيه قوات فاجنر من نقص في الذخيره
وايضا تصعيد في الخلافات مع قاده الجيش
الروسي عامل الوقت الذي تحدث عنه قائد
القوات البريه الاورك الاوكرانيه
اوليكسندر سيروسكي هو الملاذ الاخير
للقوات الروسيه طبعا الاستمرار الصمود
وعدم الانسحاب كما حدث في سوليدار من قبل
شرسكي قال انه يجب كسب الوقت من اجل شن
هجوم مضاد خاصه ان كيف تعول على اسلحه
الغرب في مواجهه التقدم الروسي في الشرق
مع ذلك لم يكن الامر بهذه السهوله وزير
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه ديمتروكوليبا اتهم
المانيا بالتردد في عدم اتمام صفقات
الاسلحه التي تعهدت بها كلا يقول ان
الشركات الالمانيه المصنعه للاسلحه جاهزه
التسليم لكنها تنتظر توقيع الحكومه على
العقود وهو لم يحدث عامل الوقت ربما لا
يكون في صالحك التقارير الغربيه تشير ان
قوات فاجنر استطاعت على مدار الايام
الاربعه الماضيه السيطره على الجزء الاكبر
من شرق باغموت وفي سبيل وقف تقدمها قامت
القوات الاوكرانيه بهدم الجسور الرئيسيه
في النهر والذي قد يقودها الى الغرب حيث
لا تزال كيف تتمسك بالامل الاخير طبعا في
هذه الاثناء قال وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا
ديمتري كوليبا ايضا انه لا يتوقع تسلم
مقاتلات جويه غربيه قريبا بسبب مشكله
لوجستيه معقده كوليبا حتى في تصريحات لصحف
المانيه على البدء في تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على الطائرات الغربيه الان
ليكونوا مستعدين عند اتخاذ قرار توفير
المقاتلات كليب اشار ايضا الى ان اوكرانيا
ستواصل الدفاع وبحزم عن مدينه الخسائر الف
ادحه مشيرا الى ان ذلك سيحمي مدن اوكرانيه
اخرى من مواجهه المصير نفسه
حول اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر
الاسود اكدت الخارجيه الروسيه عدم وجود
مفاوضات بشان التمديد حيث تنتهي الاتفاقيه
في الثامن عشر من مارس وقلت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه ماريا زخاروفا ان موسكو على
درايه بتصريحات اطراف مختلفه من بينها
النظام الاوكراني بشان تمديد اتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب مؤكده ان لا مفاوضات جاريه
بهذا الشان اضافت ان الجوله التاليه من
المشاورات بين طبعا الوفده الروسي والامم
المتحده ستنعقد في جنيف
[موسيقى]
وحول تصعيد بين مولدوفا وروسيا زعم رئيس
المفتشيه العامه للشرطه المولدوفيه فيوريل
تشيرنيو تشانو زعم ان الاجهزه الامنيه
الروسيه تعمل على اثاره الاحتجاجات بهدف
زعزعه استقرار الوضع في البلاد واوضح ان
التقارير التي تلقتها الشرطه تفيد بقيام
الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه بالتحضير لزعزعه
استقرار الوضع في الجمهوريه في فبراير
الماضي شددت الخارجيه الروسيه على ان هذه
الاتهامات اتهامات
كيشيناو حول خطه روسيا لزعزعه استقرار
الوضع في مولدوفا لا اساس لها من الصحه
مشيره الى ان الهدف الحقيقي لكياب والتي
ادلت بدورها بمثل هذه التصريحات الهدف هو
جر البلاد الى مواجهه مع روسيا على حد وصف
السلطات الروسيه
في هذه الاثناء افاد مراسل العربيه بتلقي
السلطات المولدوفيه انذار بوجود قنبله في
مطار العاصمه بحسب احد رجال الامن فقد
تلقت السلطات هناك اتصال يحذر من وجود
عبوه ناسفه داخل المطار قوات الامن سرعت
باجراء عمليات بحث كما وقد تم اخلاء
المطار من جميع المسافرين والموظفين ونقل
من عبروا منطقه الجوازات بحافلات حافلات
المطار الى مكان بعيد عن مبنى المطار
الى ايران الان حيث اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبد اللهيان التوصل
لاتفاق مبدئي لتبادل السجناء مع واشنطن
وقال عبد الله للتلفزيون الايراني ان
طهران تسعى لتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق في اسرع
وقت ممكن فيما افادت مراسلته العربيه ان
الصفقه بين واشنطن وطهران تتضمن اطلاق
ثلاثه
رهائن امريكيين في ايران مقابل افراج
واشنطن عن اموال لطهران في العراق
المزيد معنا من دبي مراسله العربيه في
واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي اهلا بك ناديه لديك
معلومات تفضلي
بالفعل ميسون حسب مصدر تحدثت معه قبل قليل
اكد لي بان صفقه تبادل السجناء وهم سجناء
ايرانيين امريكيين بمعنى مزدوجي الجنسيه
وهم سماك مادي مراد
سيتم الاخراج عنهم مقابل طبعا الاموال
التي تحتجزها ثلاث دول وهي العراق اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه هذه الاموال تصل الى 10
مليار دولار وطبعا الاتفاق بدا
باداره اوروبا مع الحج على هذه الاموال في
العراق بالامس لكن سيقول باقي الدول على
ان تكون هناك دوله وثيقه هناك بنك ربما في
عمان ربما في قطر لم تتاكد المعلومه حتى
الان سيكون مشرف على هذه الاموال طبعا كان
الحديث السابق عن بنك في اوروبا لكن يبدو
بعد العقوبات الاخيره لم يستطع بنك اوروبي
ان يزرع هذه الاموال وبالتالي ستكون في
بلد مثل عمان ربما هذه الاموال اريد ان
اؤكد حسب المصدر الذي تحدثناه ستكون
للاستخدام الانساني فقط لن تستطيع ايران
استخدام هذه الاموال لدعموا في المنطقه او
لاي غرض تكون فقط
الاسباب الانسانيه للاغراض الانسانيه
بالدرجه الاولى
نتحدث عن ثلاثه نهائي المحتجزين في سجون
الايرانيه منذ فتره طويله
قد ظهر على محطه قبل
فتره هذه بدايه يعني
خطوات بناء ثقه اذا اردت بعد الاتفاق بين
المملكه السعوديه وما بين ايران قد يبدو
بان هناك تم يعني المساهمه ربما في دفع
هذا المسار هو مسار منفصل تماما بين
واشنطن وبين طهران قد ايه عمر هذا المسار
نادي البلبيسي فيما يتعلق
بالرهائن وبالمقابل هل من بقي هناك من
اسماء نعرفها
نعم هناك اسماء طبعا اذا تحدثنا مع اللجنه
التي تتابع
الرهائن في كل العالم لجنه الامريكيه
وتسمى هناك سيبقى شهاب
دليلي هو حاصل على الاقامه في الولايات
المتحده لكنه لا يملك الجنسيه الامريكيه
ربما لذلك ترك نوعا ما لمرحله قادمه لكن
هذه اللجنه التي تتابع الاسرى في كل
العالم وبالتحديد في السجون الايرانيه
تقول بانه يجب ان تضم كل امريكي لديه
اقامه لديه جنسيه لديه بطاقه خضراء موجود
في سجون الايرانيه يجب ان يتم فيها اطلاق
سراح القياده الصفقه لكن حسب علمي هناك
اثنين منهم شهاب دلالي على الاقل الاسم
الذي اعرفه حتى الان وهذا نتحدث عن
الولايات المتحده فقط هناك من جنسيات اخرى
من دبي ناديه البلبيسي مراسله العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
نبقى في ايران حيث ايدت المحكمه العليا
بايران حكما باعدام المعارض الايرانيه
السويدي حبيب فرج الله وجاء هذا بعد ان
بدات المحكمه الثوريه في طهران في محاكمته
في شهر يناير الماضي بعد اكثر من عام على
احتجازه فرج الله اتهم ايضا بالتخطيط
لاعمال ارهابيه وقيادتها وبتزعم حركه
النضال العربي لتحرير الاحواز التي تنشط
في جنوب غربي ايران
وحول ازمه تصميم الطالبات في الداخل
الايراني اعلنت السلطات هناك توقيف اكثر
من 100 شخص داخل ايران في طبعا اطار
التحقيق في حوادث التسمم التي طالت مئات
التلميذات واثارت غضب عارم داخل البلاد
الداخليه قالت في بيان لها انه جرى تحديد
اكثر من 100 شخص كانوا متورطين في الحوادث
المدرسيه الاخيره حيث تم اعتقالهم وفتح
التحقيق معهم لم تذكر الوزاره تفاصيل عن
الاشخاص الذين اعتقلوا في محافظات عده من
بينها طهران وقم واذربيجان الشرقيه
والغربيه
ومحافظتي كردستان وهمدا
وفي هذه الاثناء عقد نواف الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري بمبنى الكابيتل
مؤتمر لتقديم توصياتهم بشان السياسه
الامريكيه تجاه ايران طبعا بحضور شخصيات
ايرانيه معارضه
وساسه امريكيين قالت المعارضه الايرانيه
البارزه مريم رجوي في كلمه لها خلال
المؤتمر قالت ان النظام الايراني فشل في
اجتثاث الانتفاضه الشعبيه رقم القمع
الوحشي الذي مارسه ضد المحتجين
رغم هذا القمع الوحشي فشل النظام في
اجتثاث الانتفاضه لان جذور هذه الانتفاضه
تعود الى الحاله المتفجره للمجتمع والفقر
والبطاله وقبل كل شيء الوضع الكارثي
للمراه
المزيد معنا من الرياض الباحث في الشان
الايراني صالح حميد اهلا بك استاذه صالح
دعني ابدا بقضيه التسمم والاعتقالات يعني
اكثر من مره سمعنا ان هناك عمليه اعتقال
لاشخاص مرتبطين في هذا الملف تحديدا لدينا
اي تفاصيل
نعم يعني في الارقام صارت الداخليه تقول
انها اعتقلت مئه شخص في احدى عشر محافظه
بانما حالات التسمم بلغت في 25 محافظه
5000 طالبه البيان الذي اصدرته وزاره
الداخليه ايضا عمل بعض التناقضات حيث قسم
هؤلاء المعتقلين المئه الى فئتين منهم قال
طلاب كان هدفهم
تعطيل المدارس
وقال انها مجرد يعني مشاغبه من الطالبات
الفئه الثانيه ربطهم بانهم عناصر معاديه
للثوره حسب البال وربطهم بالمعارضه في
الخارج لكن بقي السؤال
انه كيف حصل هؤلاء المئه على هذه المواد
علما ان الكثير من الخبراء بما فيه
الخبراء في وزاره الصحه يقولون ان هذه
المواد لا يمكن عليها مواطنين عاديين
تلاميذ
استاذ صالح هو هذا الغموض يعني لحد الان
عدم الكشف عن نوعيه المواد عدم تزويد
الاهالي بنتائج الفحوصات ونتائج التي
السلطات نفسها التكتم على الموضوع تهديد
المدارس والمعلم بعدم
بايه حقائق تعزز الشكوك حول تورط جهات
مرتبطه بالنظام متنفذه داخل ولكن يعني هذا
يؤثر على صوره وسمعه ايران
صحيح لكن الهدف هو كما يقول الكثير من ان
الشيطان هو اخافه الفتيات خاصه لانه
المدارس كانت على مدى خمسه اشهر تخرج
التلاميذ خاصه فتيات الثانويات مع
المظاهرات والاحتجاجات الشعبيه ثانيا حراك
الحياه
المراه والحياه والحريه وكانوا عنوانا
للاحتجاجات الشعبيه ايضا الهدف هو الرعب
لانه الى حد ما تحقق هذا الهدف لانه لغايه
اليوم الكثير من العوائل لا ترسل بنات
المدارس اليوم حاول وزير التربيه والتعليم
طمانه العوائل وقال انهم يستطيعون ارسال
بناتهم الى المدارس لكن لا زالت هناك حاله
من الخوف حاله من الهلع وكاني افهم من
كلامك سيد صالح ان محاوله وطريقه جديده
لقمع التظاهرات رجعوا تقول بانه مهما حاول
النظام لم او قالت بالاحرى ما قام به لم
ينجح بقمع التظاهرات هل يمكن لمثل هذه
الحوادث ان تؤثر على الشارع وعلى موقفه
على خروج الفتيات بالفعل
يعني ايه المظاهرات ولو خفت حدتها وشكلها
لكنها ما زالت مستمره اليوم كانوا هناك
تجمعات عديده في المدن الايرانيه للعمال
للمتقاعدين حتى هناك تجمعات كانت لادانه
هذه حالات التسمم وحاله طريق التعاطي
السلطات مع الموضوع اريد فقط ان اضيف
موضوع وان المعارضون يقولون ان
ربما هناك يعني تجربه
لنوع من استخدام المواد الكيماويه شبيهه
بالحاله السوريه ويربطون ذلك بتصريحات علي
حاج زاده قائد القوه الجويه بالحرس الثوري
الذي قال في قبل ايام ان في التعاون مع
الاحتجاجات الاخيره استخدمنا التجربه
السوريه فلذلك هذا الغموض وطريقه التعاطي
الازدواجيه وكل هذا التكتل من قبل السلطات
يعزز التهم والشكوك ضد سلطات
بالتواطئات على كل انسانه معنا من الرياض
الباحث في الشان الايراني صالح حميد شكرا
جزيلا لك
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
تمتتل كل هذه المجموعه 22 تم التعرف على
14 جثه منهم جهاز مكافحه الارهاب بالعراق
يعلن مقتله 22 عنصرا بداعش من بينهم قيادي
في ديالى
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
امريكا بالتحديد حول الازمه ازمه انهيار
بنك سيليكون فالي والذي يعد اكبر افلاس
مصري في امريكي منذ الازمه الماليه عام
2008 حيث اكدت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
طبعا تعليقا على هذا الانهيار ان الاقتصاد
الامريكي والنظام البنكي يظلان امنين
اشارت الى ان انهيار سيليكون فالي
هو صادم ومقلق لكنها لفتت ايضا الى ان
مرور احد البنوك بازمه لا يعني ان بقيه
البنوك ستعاني وان الاداره الامريكيه تسعى
لعدم انتقال مشاكل بنك سيليكون فالي الى
بنوك اخرى
المزيد معي من لندن دكتور طارق الرفاعي
وهو الرئيس التنفيذي لمركز كرم للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك دكتور اسمح لي ان
ابدا بقراءتك للمشهد هل فعلا بالرغم من
انه المشهد مقلق ولكنه غير مؤثر كما كنا
نتحدث ب 2008
نعم المشكله يعني له شبه لازمه 2008 ولكن
المشكله مع البنك اليوم مختلفه تماما من
اللي شفناه مع المشتقات الماليه في 2008
شو الفرق
اولا المشكله البنك هو يعني
محاوله
يعني عدم الثقه في البنك الفيدرالي لرفع
اسعار الفائده خلال فتره الجائحه مما ادى
البنك الى
استثمار بشكل كبير في السندات الامريكيه
الطويله الاجل ومع ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
طبعا شفنا الخسائر الغير محققه للبنك
تراكمت الى تقريبا 15 مليار دولار هذا
اللي ادى الى انهيار البنك طيب وهاي فتره
كافيه ربما
تدارك او ربما ايجاد حلول اخرى او لا لانه
دكتور طارق عندما يقولون اغلق بعد ان وجد
نفسه فجاه في عسر كيف وجهها
ما كانت فجاه للبنك لانه طبعا حسب تصريحات
البنك من العام الماضي بدينا نرى تراكم
الخسارات في هذه السنادات وطبعا كل ما
اصرحوا في هذه الخسارات طلع البنك في
تصريح اخر يؤكد على مدى يعني امان وضمان
البنك الى اخره طبعا هذا كان يعني متفائل
جدا في يعني مدى رفع اسعار الفائده من قبل
البنك الفيدرالي كل ما رفع البنك
الفيدرالي نسبه الفائده كل ما شفنا تراكم
تتسارع للخصارات في البنك
التاثير ليس بالقوي ذكر الدكتور طارق ولكن
عاده ما يقال اذا ما عطست الولايات
المتحده تصاب باقي الدول بانفلونزا هل
يمكن ان نتاثر ولو قليلا
لازم ناخذ بالاعتبار مشكله البنك هذه
مختلفه تماما من المشاكل الاخرى طبعا انا
اذكر انه
ارتفاع اسعار الفائده اللي شايفينها اليوم
في امريكا وحتى في اوروبا وبريطانيا الى
اخره لها تاثيرات سلبيه على كثير من
القطاعات حول العالم فيعني
الان انهيار البنك هذا هذه اول لمحه
لمدى تاثير ارتفاع اسعار الفائده فممكن
نرى تاثير على قطاعات اخرى مثل القطاع
العقاري بدانا نرى ملامح في بريطانيا الى
اخره وحتى في الدول العربيه دكتور او لا
في الدول العربيه غير لان هي يعني مختلفه
تماما من ناحيه الاقتصاد وتنويع الاقتصاد
وطبعا القطاع المصرفي في امريكا وفي
اوروبا
تشبه النسبه اكبر من الاقتصاد من الدول
العربيه طيب
قراءه انخفاض ولكن من ثم عاده وانتعشت ليش
من اين اجت البنوك الكبرى ما هي يعني
تاثيرها قليل جدا وليس ملحوظ على هذه
البنوك لان البنوك هذه طبعا
متنوعه تماما في جميع المجالات الاقتصاديه
في وطبعا التركيز الان على البنوك التي
تستثمر في قطاع التكنولوجيا وانا باعتبار
ان هذا غير صحيح لابد ان نرى سبب انهيار
البنك سبب انهيار البنك هو الاعتماد على
الاستثمار في السندات طويله الاجل مقابل
ارتفاع اسعار الفائده من قبل البنك
الفيدرالي في انا اعتقد انه في بنوك ثانيه
موجوده في الاقتصاد الامريكي الان وحتى في
الاقتصاد الاوروبي والبريطاني
عملوا نفس الخطا وبالتالي ما هي الحلول
دكتور طارق ومن بيده الحل او العصا
السحريه اذا مصحه التعبير بهذا الاطار
احنا طبعا افان الاوان يعني فات الاوان
لايجاد حلول لهذه المشكله لابد ان يعني مش
مشكله البنك انت عم بتقول انه ممكن يكون
من سيتاثر بسبب ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
وغيره وبالتالي شو طبيعه القرارات التي
يجب ان تتخذ بهذا الوضع
القرارات هذه موجوده ولكن الهيئه الرقابيه
ما كانت يعني يعني
مضمونه وما كانت موجوده في البنك يعني حتى
يعني الان نسمع الكلام انه الهيئه
الرقابيه ما كانت
تراقب البنك بشكل اساسي بسبب قله الراس
المال الموجود كثره المخاطر في هذا البنك
فيعني القوانين والرقابه موجوده ولكن
التنفيذ في هذه القوانين ليست موجوده من
لندن دكتور طارق الرفاعي الرئيسي التنفيذي
لمركز كولم للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
يتوجه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريش سوناك
الى الولايات المتحده للقاء الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وايضا رئيس الوزراء
الاسترالي انتيوني من اجل الانتهاء من
تفاصيل صفقه الغواصات النوويه طبعا ياتي
ذلك بموجب تحالف اوكسات الثلاثي الذي يهدف
لمواجهه الوجود العسكري المتنامي للصين في
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا بالعوده الى الوراء قبل
سبعين عاما اجتمعت كل من الولايات المتحده
وايضا بريطانيا واستراليا لمواجهه في ذلك
الوقت اليابان الان تتحد الدول الثلاث مره
اخرى لدرء ما وصفوه بالعدوان الصيني في
محيط الهندي والهادئ وذلك طبعا في ادار
هذا التحالف الثلاثي حيث تستعد استراليا
لشراء ثماني غواصات امريكيه تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه ما سيجعلها الدوله السابعه في
العالم التي تشغل هذا النوع من الغواصات
بحسب
موقعا للاتفاقيه التي ابرمها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريجيسوناك ورئيس وزراء استراليا
البانيز سيتم بناء هذه الغواصات النوويه
في استراليا ولكن سيتم تطويرها وبشكل
مشترك مع المملكه المتحده تحت مراقبه من
واشنطن تقديرات مستقله تشير الى ان
التكاليف تكاليف بناء وايضا توريد ثمانيه
غواصات على مدى 30 تصل الى 82 مليار دولار
تتميز تلك الغواصات والتي تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه بقدرتها على التخفي وايضا السفر
لمسافات طويله ويمكن تحميلها بصواريخ كروز
متطوره ما سيجعلها قوه ردع هائله لاي عدو
محتمل من ناحيه اخرى عبرت بكين عن
معارضتها الشديده لمشروع تحالف او كرسي
الذي تعتبره خطرا يهدف الى محاصره الصين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا صراع اخر يتنمى بين واشنطن وبكين
والذي قد يدخل الى مرحله جديده طبعا مع
تعيين الاخيره اي الصين وزيرا للدفاع وهو
على قائمه عقوبات وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
لشنكوفو انتخب صباح هذا اليوم وبالاجماع
من المجلس الوطني لنواب الشعب الصيني وهو
اعلى هيئه تشريعيه بالبلاد يخضع عشان
طفولي عقوبات امريكيه منذ عام 2018 حينما
اتهمته واشنطن بالتعامل العسكري مع روسيا
حيث كان يتراس في ذلك الوقت اداره التدريب
والتموين بالمجلس العسكري المركزي الصيني
تض القيود المفروضه على وزير الدفاع
الجديد حظر تاشيرات الدخول الى الاراضي
الامريكيه حظر المعاملات مع النظام المالي
الامريكي ومصادره جميع الممتلكات داخل
الولايات المتحده بحسب بلومبرج يشير صعوده
الى اعلى منصب عسكري في البلاد الى تركيز
بكين المتزايد على تكنولوجيا الدفاع الجوي
حيث شغل مناصب في مركز لاطلاق الاقمار
الصناعيه اشرف على اطلاق اول مسبار قمر
صيني وخلال فتره وجوده هناك اطلقت الصين
بنجاح اول صاروخ مضاد للاقمار الصناعيه
يرى مراقبون ان هذه الخطوه قد تزيد من
التوترات بين البلدين لا سيما العلاقات
العسكريه التي قد تشهد انسداد في عهد وزير
الدفاع الصيني الجديد
حذرا مشاهدينا ياتي ذلك ايضا بعد ان اعلنت
بكين مطلع الشهر الجاري ان ميزانيه دفاعها
سترتفع بنسبه 7.2% هذا العام لتبلغ 245
مليار دولار في اكبر زياده لها منذ 2019
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المزيد
الصحفي الصيني اهلا بك اسمح لي ان ابدا
بقراءتك لهذا المشهد عندما تتخذ الصين
قرار بتعيين رجل مثل هذا له وضعه الخاص
فيما يتعلق بالولايات المتحده هل هي
بالتالي غير معنيه بموقف الولايات المتحده
وما يمكن ان يترتب عليه من تبعات او انه
هو مواجهه مباشره مع الولايات المتحده
اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا بكم
واعتقد عن اخو لا علاقه لتعيين وزير
الدفاع سينيه جديد بالعقوبات الامريكيه من
المعروف ان جيش صيني والامريكي رفيع
المستوى وكان لديهم دائما وسائل القنوات
للاتصال من اجل تبادلات معلومات عسكريه
واذا
بسبب العقوبات الامريكيه اذا فقدت هذه
قنوات
والوسائل الانتصار بين بكين واشنطن فمن
الواضح ان الولايات المتحده يجب ان تتحمل
المسؤوليات الكامله اعتقد بمعنى اخر انت
تقول انه الصين تقوم بما تريد وتضع
الولايات المتحده امام الامر الواقع غير
معنيه باي موقف او تصعيد ممكن ان يحدث
لانه بالفتره الاخيره احنا حسينا انه لا
في هناك قبول للتقارب بين البلدين
اعتقد ان اداره بايدن كانت
تنشروا وتبالغ النظريات تقليدي السيني من
اجل تحقيق اهدافها السياسيه وكما قالت
وزير الخارجيه صيني ان الصين لا تتنافس مع
الولايات المتحده على الخيمنه ولكن من
المستحيل عدم ردي على
الولايات المداهده اتوقف عن تشويه السمعه
السين وخالق
العزالي لشن حروب تجاريه وخروب
التكنولوجيه وخلوبي لمعلومات ولذلك اعتقد
ان تدبير العلاقات الصينيه امريكيه يعتمد
على ما اذا كانت سياسه واشنطن تجاه الصين
يمكن عن تعود الى مسارها لصاحيق واذا
استفادت
اقاطعك بهاي النقطه لانه بحسب ما افهم كان
في زياره لم سؤول كبير امريكي الى الصين
وقد تم تاجيلها بسبب المنطاد الصيني اللي
يقال بانه هو اللي بحاول ان ان
يحصل على معلومات من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومش منطاد واحد اكثر من واحد
وبالتالي يبدو ان الصين ايضا لا تقوم بما
يجب ان يقام للتخفيف من وطاه التوترات
في زيارات رفيعه مستوى
في المؤتمر الصحفي
بالحوار وتبادلات مع مع واشنطن في في
مختلف المجالات ولكن اعتقد ان كما قلت
تواصل
مبالغه نظريتها تحديد من صين فاذا اعتقد
ان هذا هذا هذا
سلوك واشنطن
اداره
بين بين البلدين نعم
الصحفي الصيني شكرا جزيلا لك
الى العراق وعلى واقع ازمه مياه تعيشها
بغداد دانه رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شياع السوداني في اطار مؤتمر العراق
للمناخ في البصره دانه الانفراد بمصادر
المياه بحسب وصفه من قبل دول المنبح حيث
بات العراق محاصرا بالجفاف رغم امتلاكه
نهري دجله والفرات نتابعه
الانفراد بحبس المياه في دول المنبع يزيد
من هشاشه الدولي في مواجهه هذه التاثيرات
ولان التاثير بالبيئه امر عابر للحدود
فاننا سندعو لمؤتمر اقليمي يعقد في بغداد
قريبا
لتعزيز التعاون والتنسيق المشترك وتبادل
الخبرات والبرامج بين دول الاقليم في
مواجهه تلك التاثيرات
ومشاهدينا
تعليقي ذكرناه في هذه النشره فيما يتعلق
باتفاق مبدئي ما بين الولايات المتحده
وايران حول اطلاق سراح اسرى طبعا في
الولايات المتحده والرهائن كما تقول
الولايات المتحده متواجدين في
معتقلين في ايران وان هذا التبادل قد تم
مبدئيا الاتفاق عليه الان الولايات
المتحده وبحسب مسؤولين تقول بانه لا صحه
لمثل هذه المعلومات التي خرجت من مصدر
رسمي ايراني يتحدث فيها عن قرب التوصل الى
هذا الاتفاق ايضا كان هناك تسريب لمعلومات
ذكرناها فيما
سبق تتحدث عن ثلاثه من المعتقلين الذين تم
الاتفاق على اطلاق سراحهم ولكن يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده تم في هذه المعلومات على
الاقل تمفي بانه هناك وصول الى اتفاق
نهائي نوافيكم بالمزيد حاله وروده ونكمل
الان من العراق حيث قال نائب العمليات
المشتركه هناك قال ان القوات الامنيه
تمكنت من قتل 22 عنصرا من تنظيم داعش في
عمليه امنيه بمحافظه ديالا وصفها بالناجحه
واضاف في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع رئيس جهاز
مكافحه الارهاب ان من بين القتلى قيادات
بارزه في التنظيم اهمهم القائد برزان علي
اضافه الى قيادات متوسطه من بينهم عرب
واجانب
الابطال من الاجهزه والوكالات الامنيه
تحديدا المخابرات وصولا الى الابطال
المنفذين على الارض باداء رائع تنقتل كل
هذه المجموعه 22 تم التعرف على 14 جثه
منهم نتيجه التحليل
وباقي الاشخاص او الارهابيين يتم تحليلها
من بيناتهم حقيقات مميزه من ضمنهم برزان
علي اللي هو يسمى الشيخ العليم كان والي
الفلوجه واحده من القاضي اعتقد ابو خالد
القاضي
والمهاجر القحطاني وتسميات كثيره لكن هو
عنصر وقياد مهم بالاضافه الى قيادات
متوسطه بالتنظيم
وبيناتهم كانوا عرب واجانب والعمليه ناجحه
على كل مستويات
ولكن بعد قليل
ما كانقلبوا على رئيسه السابق ويكشف عن
تصريحات ترامب خلال احداث الكابيتول ويقول
التاريخ سيحاسبك
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اعلن ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان عن
تاسيس ناقل جوي جديد في المملكه يسمى
طيران الرياض للمساهمه في تطوير قطاع
النقل الجوي وتهدف شركه طيران الرياض
لاطلاق رحلات تصل لاكثر من 100 وجهه حول
العالم بحلول العام 2030 ستكون الشركه
مملوكه بالكامل لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه
السعودي ومن المقرر ان تسهم في نمو الناتج
المحليه الاجمالي غير النفطي للمملكه
بقيمه تصل الى 75 مليار ريال مع استحداث
اكثر من 200 الف فرصه عمل مباشره وغير
مباشره
من جانبه قال وزير النقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه في السعوديه المهندس صالح
الجاسر قال للعربيه ان الناقل الجديد
طيران الرياض يعتبر مكمل لما تقوم به
الخطوط السعوديه التي ستتركز عملياتها
طبعا مستقبلا في مطار الملك عبد العزيز
بجده
الناقل الوطني الجديد الطيران الرياض
سيكون محور عملياته مدينه الرياض
وسيربط الرياض ببقيه العالم
وهو يكمل العمل الذي تقوم به الخطوط
السعوديه التي ستتركز
عملياتها مستقبلا من مطار الملك
عبقيه انحاء العالم وبذلك تتكامل اجراءات
تنفيذ الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه في مجال الطيران
واستراتيجيه طيران المدني بالمملكه
وتبعا لمعه لنا عنه سابقا من تاسيس المطار
الاضخم بالعالم مطار الملك سلمان بمدينه
الرياض
في السودان وعلى واقع الازمه السياسيه
الراهنه اكد المتحدث باسم الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي ياسر عرمان اكد وجوب ان
يكون رئيس وزراء السودان سياسيا معتبرا ان
حكومه تكنوقراد ليست خيارا اسرع وقت في
الضغط وفي نقاش وانا بقول لك في تفاهمات
في تفاهمات حول التسريع والتفاهمات دي
بتشمل العسكريين والمدنيين في تفاهمات حول
التسريع بانهاء عمليه واختيار رئيس
الولاده العمليه تضر تضر بالاقتصاد والامن
السوداني
اهم ما قضيتين قاعد تضر بالامن والاقتصاد
ولذلك التسريع بها مفيد للسودان عشان
السودان يكون عنده حكومه والناس يجربوا
الحكومه يكون في المعارضه
الى الولايات المتحده حيث يبدو ان
المنافسه داخل الحزب الجمهوري لنيل الثقه
للترشح في انتخابات 20 24 على اشدها فبعد
حرب التصريحات بين ترامب وروندي سنتيز
حاكم فلوريدا الان دخل على الخط مايك بنس
نائب دونالد ترامب في فتره رئاسته طبعا
هجوم مبنى الكونجرس عام 2021 هو الباب
الامثل يدخل منه في صراعه مع ترامب فمع
فتح وزاره العدل الالباب امام مقادات
ترامب في مسؤوليته عن هجوم الكابيتال لم
يفوت بنس الفرصه حيث شن على ترامب هجوما
لاذعا اعتبر هو الاشد بنس كان شاهدا على
الاحداث عندما اقتحم الالاف من انصار
ترامب المبنى في محاوله لمنع الكونجرس من
التصديق على النتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لعام 2020 والتي خسرها ترامب امام جو
بايدن لما يصدر عن تعليق يذكر بشان
الحادثه في الاشهر التاليه كما رفض
التعاون لجنه مجلس النواب المعنيه
بالتحقيق في الهجوم لكنهم كثف مؤخرا من
انتقاداته لمثيري الشغب وترامب في تغير قد
يفهم على انه خطوه نحو ازاحه ترامب من
الترشح في الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
قال
انتقادات على استحياء لترامب ولكن هذه
المره اتهمه مباشره
بتعريض عائلته للخطر قال ان التاريخ
سيحاسبه على دوره في الهجوم لم يتوقف
الامر عن ذلك لكنه وصف ما حدث في ذلك
اليوم بانه وصمت عار تشير تعليقات بنس الى
انه مستعد للنائيه بنفسه اكثر عن ترامب مع
احتدام الحمله الانتخابيه الرئاسيه التي
تجري في 20 24 حتى وان كان هذا يعني خساره
دعم ملايين الناخبين الجمهوريين الذين لا
يزالون يؤيدون ترامب
المزيد معنا من واشنطن مراسل العربيه حسين
الطوض اهلا بك حسين هل للتصريحات هذه
المباشره مفاجئه
لا ميسون هي ليست مفاجئه وكان من المتوقع
ان كان متوقعا ان يهاجم
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب كخطوه تحضيريه
على ما يبدو
لتهيئه الراي العام الجمهوري على الاقل
لخوضه المنافسه من اجل حصول على ترشيح
الحزب الجمهوري لمنافسه ترامب وربما ايضا
رئيس جواتنا اول مرشح عن الجهه
الديمقراطيه ولكن دعيني اشدد على شيء مهم
الان زعماء الحزب الجمهوري العديد منهم
يحاولون النائب بانفسهم عن ترامبو يدعونه
ايضا الى التخلي عن ترشحه او حملته للحصول
على الحزبه الجمهوري لانهم يرون ان سلسله
التحقيقات والقضايا المرفوعه ضده سيكون
لها تحديات على الحزب في الانتخابات
المقبله اذا كان هو المرشح لمواجهه بايدن
ويقولون بانه ترامب هو المرشح الجمهوري
الوحيد الذي قد يهزمه ايضا هذا كلام
محررين حتى جمهوريين في الوقت الذي يعتبر
ترامب انه المرشح الجمهور الوحيد الذي
يستطيع ان ينقذ امريكا من الجمهوريين وفق
ما يعبر عنه دائما ده نسبه هؤلاء حسين
وقديه مدى قوتهم وفعاليتهم في طرح هذه
النقطه
ميسون اذا كنا نتحدث عن القاعده الشعبيه
للحزب الجمهوري فتره حتى الان هو لديها
النسبه الاكبر من التاييد لدى الجمهوريين
لكن عندما نتحدث عن زعماء الحزب الجمهوري
هم نسبه قويه وهم معظم الحزمه الجمهوري
الان يحاولون النائب بانفسهم عنهم نذكر
الان ماي قاد يرشح نفسه وايضا نذكر
وسنتابع التطورات والعديد من القضاء
الجمهوريين
شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا عبد الله وبهذا نكون قد واصلنا
مشاهدينا الى نهايه الخامسه لمتابعه ملفات
العربيه المزيد من الاخبار والتحليلات
تابعوا موقعنا العربيه نت رجاء مسح الكود
الظاهر على الشاشه نلتقي باذن الله غدا
ونشره جديده في الخامسه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]